今日は外れそうです今日はお越しれるものを見つけましたこちら
あー目がバルーンですジャイアントサイズファンメートルのバルー
こういう感じですねすごい巨大なバルーンがあるんですけどもなんとこちら最大約
30m とぶっぱ
っていうわけで犯罪けど目が張る作ってみますと作り方も結構簡単みたいですまず外に
走ってなんかぱらっと使用的なね ok わーっ悪い
で国民ってちょっとあって結構でかいの羽根を広げてバダは広げ空気をいれば走ってネ
スってきます
どうかえっそれー抹茶である程度空気が入ったらいいけど既婚でくださいと
めっちゃ親鸞スっているチーム
どうどうぞメット長いね比較うーん
小山呼ば先これ言ってねー
このが付属していたどんどんで留めますハイメガバレーの完成です
やわけないっ
マスコット日横になってみても僕と全く同じサイズでございます
はいこんなサイズ感になっております投げると30m ぐらいと打って帰って行ったの
でちょっと捧げつなぎてみましょう
あっはっは2放送とは知っ
えっ結構 osoro
うわぁ名前魚わー
23歳でした yeah
優しいおねえかなり飛ぶことがわかったと思いますが僕は花芽が張るんじゃ何属しない
今回目が悪に使用する特殊なアイテムはこちら
ん
はいこちらへリーヴがすごく頑張ってしまったただの空気すらあんだけと縁がダルも彼
の中にこのヘリウムガスを入れるとの体験いきますよ普通の空気の重さですがあれだけ
飛ぶってことはただヘリウムガスを入れると同じな方で500m くらい飛びますて
強い飛んで打って0 maga 捨てるなんて数戦とか動かすときに使われるガスと
空気よりかなり軽いので
そしたら根が張るが気がバルーンになるかもしれんよ
うーんちょっとされなかったみたいな
完全にも地点が違ってくるアイテムで少し小さくなりましたらヘアー任せる目が悪いと
ねしました
だから飛ばしていこうと思いますで来ていきますぜひ位
てえーっ
れたいぃぃ
一つだけぼは
までをもずぞあ
うーんたった今出なかった友会自分が住んでても大して変わらないむしろ悪化している
原因なんですけど部屋真上にいく力があるのではみでね空気の多さがあったからさっき
みたいな女が悪いは結構飛んだと思うんですけども
さて次はですねこのまだあまりの部分が結構あるので nms と空気を混ぜて入れれ
ばたぶん最初の女がバルーンよりもっと飛ぶんじゃないかと思うのでちょっとこの
あまりの分
web のところも空気を入れて満帆にしてもう1回飛ばすみようと思います
夫婦とヘリウムガスの合体バー準備が張るおめでとう間違いなく飛ぶだろ
空気ほど重くもなく lm ほど軽くはない完璧だ
では早速飛ばすみようと思います提案つい
いっ
わっっ
それで汚損寝るジョブでえっ
ケッツトンネルはどんな良いん
はっ
成功したが下手落ちがねえんだよね
白っっ
eme
me